hello everyone
so we're julian and hey i'm willie
and uh we work for datakin
and today we're going to talk about
data lineage with apache airflow using
open lineage
so putting open image and airflow
together to get some real-time lineage
and observability
and of course you know datakin is the
principal
sponsor of open lineage and marquez
marquez is the reference implementation
of open lineage and astronomer is the
company
behind airflow
and on that
there's one more thing we wanted to talk
about
and announce today and
bear with me in the microphone
and so
we have been acquired by
astronomer and so we now join forces
and it makes a lot of sense of course to
have operations and observability
together
and you know you can have a lc feedback
loop and
make sure your dags run properly and be
able to see it and really get
observability working together yeah and
the key thing with astronomer i mean
they they're so key to the
airflow community so they'd be
contributing back and they become the de
facto standard uh to want to run your
workloads and at datakin we were trying
to solve the lineage problem uh it's a
really tough thing we came up with a
standard called open lineage that we'll
go into and it just makes so much sense
that especially when we met the team
we're all super excited to join
yeah it makes your uh and there's really
shared dna on open source obviously and
makes your observability actionable
and of course
we dedicated steel accepts
signups for the service and we keep
supporting our users
while we're integrating in the astro
cloud
and on that we'll get to our
presentation today
so today
we'll talk about the need for lineage
metadata
and
open lineage and marquez and which is an
open standard for lineage collection
markets is their reference
implementation
and then we'll go in the more practical
part of the presentation talking about
actual
observability in airflow
excuse me there's a lot of lag on this
screen in the front
thank you
so the key for
uh is data lineage ready it's really
important
um to be able to understand for each job
what data set it's reading from and what
data set it's running to and for each
data set not only who produces it but
who consumes it right so it's kind of
for the core
of this this talk and really thinking
about lineage and not only lineage and
what data set is derived from what data
set or column but really understanding
the processes would
transform this data
and really understanding this lineage as
the by graph of data set to job to data
set to job graph where the metadata
around the transformation is also very
important
and so the first step is to really
enable building this healthy
data ecosystem so usually if you think
about an organization growing and
different teams start consuming and
producing data usually within a team you
have
a good practices and people know how
things are running how dependencies work
how
what are people supposed to do and how
they're supposed to
produce data however as soon as you have
team boundaries that's where you have a
lot of friction because people don't
necessarily
know how data gets updated where it's
coming from
the semantics between certain things and
that's typically as team grow and they
become
more data aware and
produce more data
that's where a lot of the friction
happens
[Music]
don't speak next to the speaker
um and so you have this limited data
context
and so it's really like okay we have
this data but where's the data source
what the schema is supposed to be is it
changing who's the owner how often is it
updated
uh where does it come from who's using
it what has changed right so there's a
lot about the current state of the data
the current schema but also how it
changes over time and who creates that
those changes
and so it's really important to collect
that
metadata as things are happening and
capture how it changes over time so that
you can get more context and reduce that
friction
so we've been borrowing this uh
data hierarchy of needs
um
i mean so mass load came up with the
master hierarchy of needs and there's a
lot of if you want to achieve
happiness and so on there's a bunch of
fundamental things you need to get first
you need to have food you need to have
shelter you need to be in a safe space
and then you can work on once you have
the
basic needs
field that's where you can try to reach
your happiness or get the best person
you can become right and so if you apply
that to data
you know before you actually can get
value out of your data there are some
basic things you need to attend right so
one
the data needs to just be available in
one way to get it
in somewhere you can look at it second
it needs to be fresh and so the data
should not be too old or outdated right
it needs to be updated in a timely
fashion and then it needs to be correct
right once you get data flowing and it
gets in time you need to make sure it's
actually correct there's no problem in
it and you can actually use it and a lot
of time in data engineering of like all
the data practices
is spent on ensuring those things right
and as long as you don't achieve this
you have your head underwater and you
can't really achieve what you want to do
with your data which like the first step
is
most of the time business optimization
making data-driven decision
and then like finding new opportunities
what next what else can we do
with your data so there's really
the baseline is about keeping our heads
above the water and being able to use
that data and be in a space that we are
not constantly fighting it and making
sure it's correct and working
and so that's where we started the open
lineage project it's really as a way to
define an open standard for the
collection of lineage as the pipelines
are running right which is really
important to really this aspect of
instrumentation and taking a page from
the open telemetry book
and not just looking at lineage after
the fact inspection that's really
instrumenting things as they're running
so we have very precise and very
granular metadata
and so to start this project
i really
took a page from previous open source
project so you know i started the
parquet project in collaboration with
cloudera when i was at twitter and then
later on i contributed to launching the
apache aero project and so there's a lot
about
when you want to build momentum for an
open source project you need to get this
critical mass at the beginning right
especially for those types of projects
which are standards
for
building something for the community
it's really important we can get
together so we can reach out in the
community get on the same page and you
know
most of the people i talk to
um we're on board with of course we need
the standard for lineage how come we
don't have it yet and the reason we
didn't have it yet because someone needs
to
get out there and push the project get
people together and like get to the
point where we can have a way a common
way of collecting lineage
and so we did that and we were lucky
enough you know through the existing
data communities to have a lot of people
either giving feedback or contributing
to the project
and so on
and really initiate this noble effect
where
you know the more people contribute to a
standard like this the more it becomes
valuable for everyone
and so there's really a snowball effect
and i've seen that happen for uh parque
i've seen that happen for arrow
it's really once you put enough effort
input in the community um towards
everyone
every single new contributor a new user
of the project adds more value for
everyone right and so there's really
building this momentum that gets the
project going and gets those standards
adopted
and so one of the key
directions for the open lineage project
is really to say the best time to
collect metadata is when that things are
happening right when you look at the
picture you could say well there's a lot
you know we could use machine learning
and ai and stuff to
figure out
metadata
start the screen just turn off
and
enable
uh capturing information you know what
time was it maybe you can infer that
from the heat of the
of the sun um you can figure out the
location how it was uh on the coast but
the other way is you can just instrument
the camera so it saves the metadata as
things are happening right so modern
cameras save
the
gps coordinates the time it was taken a
lot of information of how the picture
was taken
and that's exactly what opening it is
open lineage is the exif metadata for
your data pipelines
and so if you think about this ecosystem
and like there's a lot of people who
consume a lineage and a lot of people
who produce lineage and today all those
projects there's
several open source projects or
proprietary software we consume lineage
they all need to talk to each other you
know you have this n square effect of a
lot of communication a lot of having to
agree on doing things a lot of
duplication of effort
and once you define your own
shared standard like this well it
simplifies the problem a lot because now
producer of lineage can focus on
producing lineage in this shared format
consumers can
focus on consuming it
and there's a lot less duplication of
effort a lot fewer conversations a lot
simpler things are streamlined and also
because we define this api
we can actually push the lineage
instrumentation into each of those
projects instead of looking at it from
the outside right like the great vision
in the future is like everyone posts
lineage in an open initial presentation
in um
there's a lot less of always catching up
of
inspecting the internals of each of
those things or figuring out
so the way it fits and you know this was
the slides we did at the beginning like
and i'm defining the vision of opening
it it's about three quarters
um there um from these slides it's
really about
making all the producer exposed lineage
and enabling a bunch of consumers to
consume that lineage and the reason is
there are lots of use cases behind
lineage and
there are a lot of specialized
tools that use look at it from a
different point of view whether it's
operations or governance or privacy of a
lot of other things and it's important
to enable an ecosystem
that can all leverage lineage and really
amortize the cost of this
so the data model
there's a
on purpose a very simple data model that
focuses on just the lineage you have
this notion of recurring jobs and we
capture each run of the job and it has
inputs and output data sets right so
that's a core it's just the lineage and
then there's very extensible model on
each of those entities in that model we
can actually add facets
and facets and i will get back to this
are these things that
really enable putting more metadata they
are self-contained pieces of metadata
that you can attach to those entities
and so the way this works
is when the job starts we send a start
event with metadata related to it when
it finishes we send an end event so it's
all very asynchronous
makes it easy to consume that metadata
from different consumers
and keep track of
things so typically you know you have a
life cycle of a job run it starts
and it's either complete
or fails or boards and you're in
different contexts those jobs are called
different things
in airflow it's a task
you know in spark you have commands uh
that are doing things
and you can model those things as open
lineage jobs
um and capture the start and
end state whether it's successful or
fail
and the facets are really these atomic
self-contained pieces of metadata each
of them has a json schema that define
them so they're self-documenting right
they have a name they have a schema
they self-contain and can be designed
independently that avoid this effect of
having a big monolithic spec right we
can focus on different aspects like
people who care about data quality can
focus on the data quality aspect data
quality metrics people who care
about a column level lineage and
governance can focus on that
thank you
[Music]
and they're flexible um
and scalable in terms of making
decisions right and we allow also
custom facets
that let you
[Music]
extend the model without having to go
through an approval process right so you
can either have the common core facets
that are going to be defined as part of
the spec or defining their own custom
facet and really make the model
extensible so you can experiment and
build on top of open lineage without
having to go through any kind of
approval process
and so just a few examples
um you know to give you an idea of the
kind of information on data sets you may
want to capture the schema and that the
schema at the time of the data set that
the data set was read or written to
what statistics you had on the data set
data quality statistics on the job you
would capture what's the version of the
code um
what was the plan at the time of the run
you know you could capture other kind of
information query pl profiles and so on
and
and like i was saying the dependencies
are endless right there the big value i
think this share instrumentation of
lineage is there a lot of use cases that
are can be built on top of this so of
course um you know datakin is focusing
on observability operation does my data
show up does it show up on time is it
correct and really this kind of
operation aspect of things
but there are a lot of people who are
interested in other things
like ensuring privacy
regulation like does my user private
data go in the right places are we not
consuming it we're not supposed to
consume it
or discovery understanding where data is
coming from and all other use cases
that can be applied to this
and on that i'm going to pass the
microphone to willy
who's going to talk about marquez and
marquez is the reference implementation
and store for opening each event
okay thank you julian
okay so a little back story about
marquez so we both julie and i we work
and we co-created the marquez project
there and
eventually that project got donated to
lfai and data foundation so we're really
excited to talk to you about marquez and
also the influence marquez project had
on open lineage and walk through you
guys through a demo and some background
okay so what is marquez marquez is an
open
lineage implementation
it also is a metadata service so it
exposes a lineage endpoint to extract
lineage information so what we look into
the payload when we receive it we look
at sources so where is your data where
does it live how do i connect to that
source you will look at data sets and
those could be
i'm sorry they could be tables they
could be a file on s3 and then the jobs
themselves so the code that actually
executes we also care about the job
entity and what are the inputs and
outputs
so if we look at the diagram on the
right you'll see
there's different use cases so your etl
jobs uh so airflow is one example and a
few others uh you know there's batch and
also
we're looking also to in improve the
open lineage spec will support streaming
but streaming data sets are
something that's supported in marquez
and you post that metadata through a
rest api
um and then the certain features so if
you
you look at data governance um sort of
understanding who has access to what
data
and so the way you kind of do that is
usually you tag your your table
or you tag your columns using the rest
api that marquez has and that way you
know does this table have pii if it does
um what are the jobs that are reading
from that table that possibly could be
pushing that pii data downstream
the other one is data lineage this is a
pretty key thing to marquez so the model
on the back end
will keep dependencies between the jobs
and the data sets that they produce and
consume as well as link those to runs
and data discovery and exploration so
marquez does have a search api
that you can use through the ui or just
hit
the rest api directly that allows you to
search data sets and jobs right now
fairly simple but we are looking to
expand that
to do a bit more interesting things
so if you remember as you only presented
on the open lineage model you have runs
you have jobs and you have data sets
marquez goes a bit deeper so there's a
versioning layer that is on top of that
so
with jobs you're going to have batch
streaming
and so forth
but for every job that you admit or
register with marquez we also do version
it but it's super lightweight we kind of
look at as the code chains because you
report that back the link to github of
where your code might be
we also look at the inputs and outputs
so as the inputs and outputs for your
job changed we also version on that and
then we associate a run to a job version
so we're constantly knowing
for every run what were the jaw version
that were produced and what i'm sorry
what were the
data set versions that were produced and
also what were the data versions as
input and what was the transformation
that happened
for data sets there's different types
right now but they usually assert that
associate them to a source so you know
you have s3 you have postgres mysql so
all those you we you want to register
and then if you look from
left to right the model
um you begin to register data sets you
begin to register jobs and now you have
this really simple
catalog of information
and on top of that you have the lineage
graph
so what are the design benefits like why
why invest or why have a model that
captures out all that information
really the debugging case a lot of the
time
you're a data engineer you're given some
sql from an analyst like
production isis and run it
once a day or weekly but sometimes that
code changes that sql does change and
when that change happens how do you know
that um or when do you know that that
bug was introduced in your code because
usually it's about a week later that
your dashboards don't look right um
either you're doing really well or
you're or it doesn't make sense like we
didn't push out a new feature in our
product yet we're seeing
the numbers um
there's an anomaly in the data so the
real question you're asking is what
version of the code produce what version
of the data set
and uh once you actually find out what
the problem is you you want to backfill
your data and that's really tough
problem right now um like do you want to
backfill all your data so you want to do
full uh full um processing so if you you
know process all all the partitions of
your data set or you want to do
incremental uh
processing
so the
the next part of my talk is going to be
around airflow observability with open
lineage so we're going to go a little
bit deep into
how the integration works with airflow
so
how how is the air how does the support
for
air airflow work with marquez so the one
thing that we look at is that when your
dag runs you have to have the marquez
library installed but these slides are a
bit old now we've been moving so quickly
and adopting the standard now you just
have to uh install the open linux
library so real real quick story the
integration for airflow
started on marquez and then we
donated the
the library to open lineage
what what does it collect in terms of
metadata the task life cycle i mean
that's just your basic your job starts
it's running uh did it fail um
the task parameters so what are the
parameters that go into your job so the
you know the common question is you know
are you providing a flag that maybe
executes
certain parts of the code so you want to
collect that to help you debug later
you have the task runs um that are
linked to version code so the
integration does support
if you are syncing your code from from
github we're able to build that link and
report it on the back end and the most
important thing is just the inputs and
outputs so if you have a postgres
operator what's and you look at the sql
what are the um what tables are you
writing to
lineage is also another big one right so
a lot of the time organizations they
they run multiple airflow instances
sometimes just one
but you don't you don't have a common
view of all the decks that are running
you normally have to click on a dag look
at his task and look at the graph
so what we end up doing is collecting
the lineage information and
understanding the inter-dac dependencies
between
between the dacs themselves and also the
tasks
and then there's built-in there's a
built-in sql parser so this is pretty
lightweight we just tokenize the sql we
look at where the uh the input tables
and also what table did you eventually
write to
and we have this link code builder so
you know this github supported gitlab
and the other important thing is just
the metadata extractors so there are the
ones that look at the operator and
extract the metadata at a surface level
and then report that to the marquez back
end as an open lineage event
and a really high level sort of
capturing the metadata from airflow and
sending it to marquez so from left to
right you have dax that execute you're
using the open lineage integration and
that reports those open these events to
marquez and marquez then eventually
populates the backend model that allows
you to then
query the api or look through it look
through that metadata and explore it via
the ui
yeah another quick thing here
currently you do have to modify your dag
we've actually been working with a team
at astronomer and also the airflow team
about introducing a task listener so you
won't have to modify your dags this is
just a kind of a really quick way it's
supported through all different um
different different airflow versions but
as of um i think airflow 2.3 there's a
task listener and it will support this
plugin which will simplify
the introduction of open lineage and
collecting that metadata but the library
is open source you can now go to open
lineage and really you just have to
modify your import
and
what really happens here so the library
looks an operator usually um there's an
operator that
you're using to to query some data
and
the extractor looks at what are the
input parameters what was the um
what what actually happens when the the
dag runs
it registers all those different tasks
to the marquez back end and then
extracts the data so mostly we look at
that sql parameter and then we parse it
and we then look at the
the source so what what source were you
connecting to so that way we could
register those data sets uh with the
with the job
and then we bundle that up and and send
it over
and really quick here so we're going to
go through just the
the sort of steps that happen as you as
the extractor looks at the operator
so for one we initially look at the
postgres connection id and that's super
important because when we register the
data set we also want to pull in the
schema and sort of as the job is running
so here we have analytics db
for our job so that this is going to be
our source
cool and then we weren't sure the data
says so after we tokenized it we kind of
looked at okay we have this really
simple
new room oh this is the task
ide okay
all right we skipped a step but there's
room bookings is the input table and the
job itself is called new room bookings
and so
that's what really happens every time
one of your dags runs so here we have
two dags
they run periodically and maybe one team
owns one dag another team owns another
but they're not really sure the
relationship that exists between the two
they just know that hey
this has to run periodically
and the connection that exists is really
the tables in between uh so you you know
to have dependencies between tasks um
that's an option but really if you want
to understand if your dag fails and
let's say if you're
you push out some new code and you're
corrupting your data you want to be able
to know
um
what was that input table that both both
dags depend on and make possibly run a
backfill
okay
we should have the demo here
okay great so
in this example we have two airflow tags
even even in a recorded demo it doesn't
go right
yeah yeah that never happens uh
oh hold on okay we are further along in
this than i thought but that might be
okay
uh yeah if you if you don't mind yeah
thank you
okay so we have two example decks here
we have one dag that um
is called counter and really really
simple uh and trivial for a reason so
the the dag itself it's now importing
the airflow
open lineage integration so you just do
a simple override there
so we have a dollar called counter is
it's going to create a table if it
doesn't exist
there's some sql there it says okay
create table and you can see they're
both sharing a source because eventually
it's going to do
increment to counter and insert it
the other dag is called sum
so the sum is just going to read from
that counters table and sum it so again
similar
uh
modification to the dag
using the open lineage import
for airflow a similar thing where it's
just sort of
populating
or creating some tables as a setup and
eventually it's just going to read uh
from the counters table so then we go to
marquez and so the decks are running on
the top right you saw that i selected a
namespace and here these are the
different tags or different jobs that
were registered
so this is what the lineage graph looks
like so the important thing with the
integration is that it pre it
appends
or adds the dag as the prefix so here
you can see counter.ink
so the ink was the task and it's in a
complete state we capture the sql from
the open linux facet and here are the
facets that openly need to collected
and at the same time
we're capturing all the different runs
so this is currently in the running
state but you can see there's previous
previous ones as well
and automatically the data
the data set was collected as well as
the schema
so you can see here
value and and the type and that was the
um
that was the schema for the table and
similarly for the job here
you know sum.total running state and
again you can see that we're reading
from the counters table and doing a sum
on the value and eventually inserting it
and again the different facets here
if this was a spark job you would see
the spark plan there
so with the version with a different run
history we look at then the output table
and here you can see it's
example.public.sums
and what we the convention that we use
there is that the name of the the data
uh the the database plus the schema and
plus the table and you can also do some
some searching as well like i talked
about before and you could do filtering
on data sets and jobs
as well and do some sorting as well
but okay that's cool
um
that's
an interesting example but what i wanted
to do is make a change to the deck so i
wanted to update the column name which
happens a lot right so oftentimes you
have to
rename a column
but how do you know who's using your
table so often times you rename it and
eventually someone pings you it's like
hey my pipeline's not working anymore
what happened
okay so we're just going to do a quick
refresh i think at this point the job
finished so if we go back everything
happens in real time so you can see here
that the table column has changed so
we're now inserting uh
i think it's called values from one to
ten so we're now just only inserting
values from one to ten and you can see
the column name just has changed
um also you could like a look at the
different run history so from run to run
you'll see that the initial run had
value and the type was int and then
similarly you know with the newest run
it's values from one to ten
also there's different versions of the
schema as well or we also version the
data set so if we clicked on any of
those you can see that initially uh
let's see this value
okay this is a job i'm sorry yeah so
that job was reading the old column
all right
so eventually this job is going to fail
um
but let's not wait it's not fun to see a
job or waited to fail so if we want to
want to skip really quick uh to 6 15
that'd be great
hey we would have to wait a long time
all right perfect
so eventually i hit refresh and what we
end up seeing is the job failed and we
kind of expected that right because the
the column name is no longer what we
expect so trying to insert or trying to
read that column
your job your job would fail so here we
just have to do a quick refresh
sometimes
what happens is um
it doesn't sync up uh because there's
there's a time on it so if we just
refresh the dag you'll see that the run
sun.total is as failing
and
you could link that to the run i did but
also the code so we know
why it's failing or in this case not
quite yet
because we don't know that the column
changed
so if we go and so let's say we spoke to
the team over slack and okay this is a
pretty simple fix so we're just going to
apply
the change to the sum the sum dag
and so now the dac has been updated
with the new sql
i'm just going to wait that uh wait for
that to refresh
okay great and i think so what we can do
also uh we could actually just check out
the code for the dag just to make sure
that that worked and when we do we
scroll down and you can see that the
the cut has been updated and refresh the
marquez ui and you'll see that the dag
should be in a running state so we're
really happy about that so we solve the
problem
cool um and then yeah you can you could
also see that we are reading the new
column so values from 1 to 10 and the
pipeline is running running successfully
but what i wanted to show really quick
as well is so you could use the marquez
ui but there also
is a rest api that's super powerful so
you can always hit the lineage endpoint
to get
a graph for a node so the node id
there's a certain format that we have
it's going to be the type of node the
namespace and also
the job names but if this was a data set
you'd give the data set name and all
we're going to be doing is just using jq
to to run it uh hit the api to get and
filter on the graph just to get the um
the
dot inc job
so what you get back is an id you get
back a type uh in this case it's a job
and also the data
uh you get the name there's a lot of
metadata that's exist in there so the
name of the job the inputs and outputs
uh so if you were going to hit the
the jobs rest api
you'd get back the same information but
now what you're able to see
is a lot more detail so you get back the
latest run so what was the latest run
for the job as well as uh
what was the state you know so the start
and end times the duration
uh the run args that were passed as well
as the version id so you could always
reference a job a job version by its id
if you want to look at
the the code that was executed we also
have version inputs and outputs in the
api
and then here you could you could always
go back and look at what was the schema
for that version by just using that
version id
you get back the context and here's just
a place to throw information so you'll
have the sequel
that was executed
as well as the open lineage facets and
the one thing that we do add in the open
lineage integration is the information
around the operator the task the version
and that
the airflow version that we executed and
you can see here we also have the in and
out edges for that node so the origin is
going to be the job and then you have a
destination
which is going to be a data set and the
one thing i do want to highlight is that
the way we register data sets is through
the source
and the one reason for why we do that is
you might have the same table name
especially if you copy data from one
source to another you're going to have
conflicts there and and also from
staging to production that's also a
possibility so we wanted to link it
by source
and one last thing
all this can be all this information is
stored in our lineage events table so
all this is logged
and the scheme itself you have the event
time the event type but we're going to
do a quick select on this table to get
the event history
so we're going to get the event time the
event type
the job the job information
and print that out
and i think the important thing here is
marquez is just one example
of what you can do with open lineage
these events they could be routed to
different systems
as well um so as this information is
coming in you could have block you could
apply your own logic on top of that
for marquez it's cataloging those jobs
and data sets and applying versioning
and exposing a linear's graph but
there's more to it than just that that
you can you can take this and uh where
you can take the standard
all right thank you
and i think with that uh what we wanted
to say was thanks for attending our talk
um we do have some information that
will eventually come up here
okay great yeah so if you want to learn
about open lineage
check us out on twitter or github same
thing for marquez
there's there's been some amazing new
new uh information that's been put up on
the marquez website and uh thanks to
ross who's in the crowd
he's done a lot of really amazing work
on the website
and uh yeah you can talk to us on slack
but also after hours
oh and we have stickers for marcus and
open lineage if you come ask questions
all right thank you thank you guys great
great presentation